صباح يوم الثلاثاء في
متجر كرسبي كريم في مولدون، تلقت مديرة المتجر كانديس
سيرجنت مكالمة غير عادية وبالنسبة لي
لم أصدق ذلك، لقد كنت
مندهشًا حقًا، أبلغ سائق التوصيل أن
الدببة كانت في الجزء الخلفي من شاحنته،
ولا توجد طريقة لتواجد الدببة فيها.  الجزء
الخلفي من الشاحنة كما تعتقد الكعك
والدببة
وبعد ذلك كنت على ما يرام، كيف يمكننا
حل هذه المشكلة؟ لقد ترك السائق الشاحنة
دون مراقبة لفترة وجيزة أثناء قيامه
بالتسليم المنتظم إلى متجر Express على Jay Bear
ما فعله.  ما أعرفه هو أن الدب الأسود
في بلدها كان الأشبال عملاء منتظمين
خارج المتجر وفي ذلك الصباح
كانوا يتجولون للحصول على شيء حلو
لتناوله، وكانت سعيدة لأنها كانت
تبحث عن القمامة وسمعت مديرة المتجر
شيلي ديانو أصواتًا قادمة من
الشاحنة وأدركت بسرعة ما كان
يحدث قلت آه إنه في الشاحنة
ثم تبعه الشبل الصغير ودخل إلى
داخل الشاحنة ثم
بدأوا للتو في تناول الكعك، التقط ديانو
بعض الصور للدببة الجائعة وهي
تمضغ الطعام، ويمكنك سماعها
مثل فتح العبوات التي كنا
نحاول التغلب عليها في الشاحنة لكنهم
استمروا في تناول جميع الكعك،
وتناولوا 20 عبوة من فتحات الدونات،
ثم أعتقد أن ستة عبوات من
ثلاث عبوات من دونات الشوكولاتة قاموا بالتجارب التي
قادت كريسبي  طاقم Kreme للقيام
بالأشياء بشكل مختلف قليلاً في
المستقبل، سنتعلم بالتأكيد كيفية
الانزلاق على المنحدر الخاص بنا وإغلاق الأبواب
لضمان عدم عودة الدببة إلى
هناك مرة أخرى، لذا فهي طريقة جيدة لحماية
منتجاتهم ولكن ليست هذه أخبار جيدة
للدببة بحثًا عن علاج لذيذ